I am thankful for my family I feel like
I never see you guys anymore didn't we
used to have a dog so let me ask you
let's go it on in this wild and wacky
world it's wacky it's so wacky I'm
having a little problem I have a
crippling addiction to opiates my body
needs it like I need oxygen so I'll do
anything to get it and I mean anything
meet an older man in a hotel I don't
care the older I get the more I realize
how important it is to golf get out and
play nine holes make the time if you
don't you'll regret it trust me
I'm sucking dick for heroin hey language
we're going to see Fleetwood Mac in
Vegas I'm sleeping in my car to prepare
for the next stage of my life and the
doctors found a lump in my breast so let
me ask you what are we gonna hear the
pitter-patter of little feet around here
I'm homeless I'm collecting cans I was
in the store earlier you know people
don't know how to ask a lot of people I
know we're dead and I just don't know
when and how it ends but I know it's
very very bad you know your uncle Jerry
my brother Jerry
Jerry's dead me and your mother are
gonna sell this apartment and use that
money to get a condo in Florida we're
very excited I'm excited about Florida
but I'm gonna miss the seasons this
seasons oh I've considered making my own
death you gotta just take a moment for
yourself
I know [ __ ] what don't you get I'm
something [ __ ] for heroin I'm the [ __ ]
you still listen that hip-hop homemade
video homi Bhabha Obama stop thinking
about tomorrow don't stop it'll soon be
here
now which one is this
[Music]